spider warren spider ward radioactive
spider worn
spider spectacular spectacular spot
awards
toby mcguire andrew gorfield gorfield
spiderman no way home
missing leaks explain
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
over the past few days we have been
treated to
a lot of spider-man no way home leaks
and then immediately following up the
leaks on the same day we got the
official releases from
marvel hasbro funko and lego now we have
all of this but we have
not gotten the trailer yet which i
actually think is a pretty good
tactic used by sony and marvel right now
releasing all of this stuff
to kind of give us a little bit of info
about the movie to get off their backs
just a little bit
because i do fully believe that all of
this was planned i definitely think it
was a marketing tactic
which is smart but the purpose of
today's video is to address something
that a lot of people have been asking me
about because if you noticed in all of
these leaks we saw
nothing for any other spider-man but tom
hollins
no signs of tobey maguire no signs of
andrew garfield
and really we didn't get any signs of
any other character that we really
haven't seen before
however that does not mean that toby and
andrew aren't going to be in the film
and it looks like they are actually
going to be getting funko pops
themselves
of their own spider-man just because we
haven't seen
any leaks of their funkos or lego sets
that they're not in the movie and in
this video i'll explain some missing
pieces of the puzzle
and of course if you love spider-man and
want to stay up to date on the mcu be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss
out on any way ahead of you so yesterday
six funko pops were revealed for
spider-man no way home
three different versions of spider-man
and then ned doctor strange and
mj and some people were thinking that
these three different versions of
spider-man could be the three different
spider-man but
they are all down holland however
closely you start to notice something
the numbers aren't in order and we're
actually missing
several numbers
those numbers don't line up in numerical
order which means there is a huge
gap in what they've chosen to release
here and what hasn't been released yet
you see here we're missing eight funkos
that they chose not to reveal
two spider-men in the sinister six
fifteen nine sixteen nine seventeen nine
eighteen
nine nineteen nine twenty and nine
twenty two and these missions counted
for us
wondering what numbers look like before
the other characters that marvel and
sony are choosing not to reveal
because again i do believe that marvel
and sony did this intentionally right
after the leaks came out they were
actually on their websites
officially posted so it seems like they
were very intentional on
what leaks got out and you notice that
there aren't really any leaks that give
us any clue towards the spider verse
i'm starting to feel like the real event
for spider-man no way home is going to
be just the trailer
really absolutely this is all just
building up to the trailer specifically
at this point right yeah at the moment
that is the main overall vibe that we're
getting because it's like someone was
speculating that or some people have
been that they released these
officially because it already started
leaking so they're like might as well
let's release sub
but still like with the specific types
of suits especially with the dr strange
one and having dr strange in there it
just starts giving you some clues as to
what might actually be featured in the
movie itself we're just getting a whole
bunch of little teasers even when the
form of funko pops
oh yeah before we finally get that
actual trailer whenever that comes out
yeah but the missing funkos that have
not been revealed yet are most likely
for those other characters that are
coming from other universes
these will be funko pops for characters
like tobey maguire spiderman
andrew garfield spider-man doc ock who
of course is confirmed for the movie as
well as elektra who was confirmed as
well and then the others are probably
going to be
the other villains such as the green
goblin sandman and all of the other ones
are rumored to appear in the movie
now they may not all be in reference to
spider-man no way home for example they
just revealed a hawkeye one and it is 9
14. so that's one of the missing pieces
but with
so many characters coming in spider-man
no way home we could probably assume
that at least
half of these missing numbers are
characters related to spider-man no way
home and we could probably safely assume
that two of them
are going to be toby mcguire spider-man
and andrew garfield
imagine holding all three absolutely
in fact they're probably going to sell
out of these funkos pretty quickly so if
you are a funko
fan be sure to get these right when they
come out and keep in mind that some of
these are walmart and target exclusive
and i'll say as much fun as like the
elite journey has been i really hope it
doesn't leak on the suits that's the one
thing i'm like i want that to be
officially unveiled when sony and marvel
want that officially unveiled yeah well
and that's see and that's something that
lends credence to me to the idea that
they might have been
full knowledge of this leak because you
know i mean
if it wasn't something that marvel was
relatively aware of or at least if it
was a big deal
i feel like things would be different
and we probably would see a bit more
than we're supposed to because even
though we don't see toby and andrew here
and then you could argue well maybe
they're not in the movie we know like
doc ock is in the movie and there's no
funko pop for knockoff yeah i have a
feeling that there's like a secret
vault that marvel's keeping those ones
just extra hidden inside
knowing full well that we're gonna look
at the numbers and look at these images
and freak out
yeah they know what they're doing they
know what they're doing i did not catch
numbers at all but a lot of people were
saying that because they didn't show any
leaks of toby maguire and andrew
garfield that means that they're not
going to actually be in the film
and that is definitely not the case
there are clearly tons of funko pops
missing here that they have chosen not
to show us and i really do believe
that they're going to wait too many
funko pop finals
to actually reveal toby maguire and
andrew garfield a few
very sure if they'll show it in the
trailer yet but we'll have to wait and
see on that
in the meantime let me know what you
think about this these missing
will only show the funko pop in the
trailer the trailer will be done in
funko pop before
it'll be like a brick film if you like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter i usually post a lot of things
on there first before doing videos
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof what a great way to
get people to go to your instagram and
twitter
i usually post things there before i
post a video and that's true because i
follow him dude
what a smart perfect call to action to
increase your social media following
respect mad respect because i have no
idea how to get people to follow me on
instagram and twitter
i post regularly there so why don't you
guys follow me on instagram and twitter
that's all i said you know it gives a
[ __ ] but war on what you said
that's some clever marketing on your
hand just post a few seconds of each
reaction
on your twitter i'm just like your face
here's a frame of my face reacting
you know the video will be up on youtube
soon well
yeah that explains it yeah i mean like i
i'm sitting here wondering like
how do they do the numbers because like
if hawkeye is 914 and he's not
attached to this movie i'm like okay so
the numbers don't necessarily
mean that there is like this sequence
from 912 to 925 is only spider-man so
like that's a bit of a ringer but yeah
it seems like there's way too much
missing that they probably just want to
keep under around john you make very
solid points and i like your points so
you make because they're so solid
like a funko pop you know they're solid
matter all right guys well spider war
and always keeping us
updated you're a spectacular spider ward
and that's for sure subscribe to
warren's channel
the amazing spider warren yeah hey let's
do it flev
doran we're getting ready to do a
patreon exclusive live stream and flev i
bet
is gonna have the most to want to talk
about the most to want to engage with us
on because phleb is reliable in that
matter i don't know what flev means
but it it kind of makes me think that if
i were to look it up in the dictionary
flev would mean
it's just just literally just loosened
and you
oh yeah and then yeah like the latin
pronunciation of letter v
is a sometimes a w sound so maybe
or something like that phleb you're
you're the chosen one my dude
thank you flev thank you you're a good
man thank you for being you you sexy
so sexy [ __ ] stop
it hard be there